yeah no thank you
hey uh what about the rest of us sorry
dude is it two for one you could have
made it it oh my god a 4-4-2 no that
doesn't sound right
no you're lost I sent out a mass email
Charlie's the only one who replied her
ago he's before one Whitby he paid for
it so how is it your for one oh because
she told me about the idea so we're even
yeah yeah I'm just kidding of course we
got some for you don't thank me thank
Charlie it's all this guy thanks charlie
thanks buddy
it's what I do hey listen man no one
else is gonna tell you this but I like
to keep it real okay you might want to
start carrying some gum around um the
boss told me the only reason you're not
getting more accounts is because of your
bad breath oh I'm sorry I eat a lot of
olives so just keep some gum on your
desk okay well yeah all right okay
oh thanks we're in this together hey
boss so I told everyone that you're
getting the office lunch for MLK Day Wow
I just didn't want you to seem racist oh
thanks
okay I love them okay I love him okay
hi Harper what are you doing keep your
mouth open
eight bus I told everyone you're
ordering the office lunch for Yom Kippur
I didn't want you to like some racist or
anything all right thanks
that's a fasting holiday hey Elliot did
you get me a mint gum oh yeah I got a
whole pack Oh perfect yeah there you go
what's your later what's with the
cupcakes for your birthday you know
what's not my birthday
who told you that it was today Harper
did mommy cupcakes happy birthday it's
not my birthday
you just wanted free food don't you have
a free cupcake in your dainty little
hand Ana yeah you do yeah and if you
want to keep getting free cupcakes
you'll keep your pretty little mouth
shut
happy birthday happy birthday and I only
had the paper three have a paid for
anything suspect old are you ok that's
good